just checking your tag
he's now live
thank you welcome good afternoon to
everybody to this scheduled
planning committee meeting before i
start i would like to confirm which
committee members are here
thank you chair um sitting for this
afternoon session of the planning
committee
um you've you have councillors william
armitage
andrew cooper mark foster roger hall
lee hartshorn carol huckabee maggie
jones
heather liggett alan powell tracy reader
kathy rouse diana ruff and pam
windley also in attendance you have
richard purcell who is the assistant
director of planning
who will be taking the role that would
normally be undertaken by adrian kirk
and the planning manager during this
meeting
you have members of the governance team
who will be supporting
you have alice lockett and emily
cartwright from the planning service
and jim fielson offering legal advice
today
thank you
[Music]
as you know we have a protocol in place
for this meeting
uh which i would now ask the facilitator
to read out
thank you chair this is just to remind
members um
to actors if you would do if you're in
the council chamber at mill lane and
just be aware that the meeting is being
live streamed
and recorded i will start the recording
for
this session now you'll hear an
announcement
this meeting is being recorded um
if all members please could speak
through the chair and remain muted
when not invited to speak you can
indicate you wish to speak by raising
your hand clearly i'll pick that up and
i'll pop it across the captions at the
bottom of the screen
you can also indicate you wish to speak
by messaging through the chat bar
if i can remind you to follow the
council procedure rules and
introducing yourself as councillor x
representing council y ward
we will be doing one poll during this
meeting of the planning committee i will
issue a poll to you
for the minutes and if the chair is in
agreement for that
um the applications that we'll consider
the voting will be conducted by roll
call
please be mindful of your home
surroundings and please keep your
cameras on for the duration of the
meeting
thank you chair thank you we'll move to
the item
first item of business apologies for
absence
um yes sure we have received apologies
uh from the following members
and council ross shipman will be
substituted by councillor pam winley
councillor peter elliott who will be
substituted by council heather liggett
councillor jane barry who will be
substituted by councillor lee hartshorne
and councillor jacqueline bridgeway who
will be substituted by councillor
margaret jones
and councilman potts who will be um
substituted by council roger hall
have we received any other apologies
not received yet thank you
the second item is for declaration of
interest members are requested to
declare the existence and nature of any
disposable pecuniary
interest and or other interests not
ready on their register of interest
in any item on the agenda and withdraw
from the meeting at the appropriate time
have we received any declarations of
interest
uh non-received chair thank you
do members have anything to declare
indications chair thank you
moving on to item three minutes of the
last meeting we now have the minutes of
our meeting held on the 25th of august
2020
are we happy that they are a correct
record
movie second oh
all those in favor
did you manage to get all of that nikki
i did that was carried chair
thank you
okay that moves us on to the main
business today as you can see
we have three applications for this
afternoon each of which has its own
report
marked items as 4a 4b and 4c
i'm happy that this is intend to
consider
them in as that order however before we
do so i would like the clerk to explain
for the benefit of members
speakers and the public who are watching
you on youtube
how they will be dealt with right thank
you chair
this is the procedure for considering
applications at the meeting
we will consider the three applications
in the order that they are set out on
the agenda
the chair will introduce the application
then ask the planning officers to refer
members
to any link comments or updates received
since the agenda was issued
the late items agenda supplement has
been published and is now on the
council's website
and the link has been sent to members
the planning officers will then give a
brief presentation
setting out the application plans and
photographs from the site
the screen showing this presentation
will be shared with those attending the
meeting
they can also be seen on the council's
website through its youtube channel
following on from this the chair will
ask each of the speakers
any ward members first followed by
objectors then the applicant or their
agent
to speak to the committee each speaker
will have
three minutes to put forward their views
using the conferencing facility
there will be a reminder given by the
clerk when 30 seconds remain
at the end of the speaker's three
minutes members of the committee will
have an opportunity to ask the speaker
questions
if necessary to clarify any points they
have made
when we have heard from all the speakers
on an application
the chair will open up the meeting for
debate by the committee
and determination by a vote
a note for the speakers once the
application you've come to speak on has
been dealt with
you may leave the virtual meeting room
however if you choose to remain then
please mute your right microphone
and turn off your camera you will not be
allowed to participate further in the
meeting
from that point now as you are aware
this meeting is being live streamed
the council will make a recording for
the purpose of preparing the minutes
once the minutes have been approved by
the committee then this recording will
be deleted
please note however that others may also
record the live stream
from the internet thank you chair
thank you we can move on to the first
application of this afternoon
which is two zero forward slash zero
zero
three four nine forward slash fl
this is an outline application with all
matters reserved
except for access layout and scale for
single stories sectional detached log
cabin within existing esquestrian
facility for holiday let accommodation
land at the northern junction of
hillhouses lane and new road wingworth
in line with our normal practice i'm
going to ask the planning officers to
tell us about any late comments reports
that have been produced and for the
planning manager to give a brief
presentation
showing any photos and plans of the site
the meeting facilitator will share the
presentation on screen
this means that i might find it
difficult to see everyone
therefore i will allow the officers to
complete their presentation
and ask members to reserve any points of
order or
questions about the process until the
end
there will be plenty of time for you to
ask any questions later thank you
planning officer are we ready to go yes
thank you chair
can we have the next slide please
thank you this is an outline application
with all matters reserved except for
access layout and scale for a single
storage sectional detached log cabin
within an existing
equestrian facility for holiday let
accommodation
the site is located to the north of the
junction of hill houses lane
and new road and is highlighted in
orange here
the site is located outside of the
settlement development limit for winger
next slide please
this slide shows the location plan which
identifies an existing equestrian
facility
access to the west of new road featuring
a timber
u-shaped stable block to the centre a
menage to the west
side and associated grazing land the
proposed log cabin would be positioned
to the north west of the existing access
and would feature two parking spaces
with the next one please thank you here
the slide shows the proposed floor
and elevation plan for the two bedroom
log cabin
moving on to the photos
thank you this photo is taken from new
road and shows the junction where hill
house is laying to the left
new road to the center and long edge
lane to the right
meet we have the next one please
this photo is taken from long edge lane
the site is located behind a mature
hedge row
to the right of the photo is the
existing access to the equestrian
facility
this is located approximately 24 meters
from the junction
and six meters from the bus stop have
the next one please
here we have the existing access point
which is taken from the west of new road
this slide shows exists in a question
facility as you can see this comprises
of a u-shaped timber stable block
next one please
this is a favorite photo of the stable
block with the menage scene in the
background
next one please
this photo shows the proposed sighting
of the log cabin this would be set back
approximately 12 metres from the highway
behind the mature hedge row
as you can see the land slopes in a
south westerly direction away from new
road and down
hill houses lane the difference in
levels from new road to the bottom of
the field is approximately 10 meters
the contours of the land have been
utilized to allow for the log cabin to
be set down approximately three to four
meters below street level
we have the next one please
this slide shows existing access and
screening which blocks any views into
the site
from a long new road the log cabin would
besides to the left of this screening
this photo is taken from a long hill
house lane looking up to the junction
with new road
the proposed log cabin would be cited to
the left of the hedgerow
and as you can see from the photo views
into the site are not possible
you have the next one please thank you
finally this photo is taken from the
public footpath number 22
which runs to the west of the site far
reaching views of the top part of the
site
are possible from here thank you nicola
outline permissions with matters
relating to access layout and scale is
sought for the single storage attached
log cabin with appearance and
landscaping details submitted at reserve
matter stage
the layout shows one detached bedroom
log cabin with access being utilized and
taken from the existing access coin
the log cabin would be positioned to the
west of the access with two parking
spaces
due to the changes in levels throughout
the site we would expect that leveling
works would be undertaken
we've received council t comments from
highways and environmental health
both of whom raised no objections
subject to the inclusion of conditions
highways raised no highway concerns as
it is considered the existing access
would be acceptable to accommodate the
increase in perceived traffic movements
associated with a single holiday let
this is subject to the inclusion of
conditions environmental health raised
comments regarding the farming
and equestrian history of the site and
as no supporting information has been
submitted
they've suggested that pre-commencement
conditions associated with
potential under contamination are
attached
they also raise comments relating to
noise and odour in relation to the close
proximity of the equestrian
activity however as
it is in the same ownership of the
equestrian use they do not raise any
concerns with this
i'm taking into account all the material
considerations it is considered that the
proposed development is acceptable in
principle
and would have an acceptable impact upon
the character of the countryside
officers are therefore making a
recommendation of approval
thank you chair thank you do we have any
questions
no questions chad no thank you we'll
move on to
the first speaker there which is the
applicant
joe firmingen
hello hello you have three minutes and
you'll be given a 30-second prompt
before the end
okay good time starts now okay
i'm speaking in support of the planning
application for
the provision of the single-story
two-bedroom cabin
there is very little holiday
accommodation within wingworth village
currently
which i think is a shame due to the
lovely surroundings and recreational
facilities that are available in the
area
and additionally it means that if extra
accommodation is needed by wingworth
residents for visiting relatives
this accommodation has to be sourced
outside of the village
the application we submitted initially
was for a three-bedroomed lodge
however concerns were raised regarding
the size of the unit
so after consultation with the planning
department it was agreed to reduce the
size of the original unit applied for by
40 from a 3-bedroom
to a 2-bedroomed lodge we're happy that
this size unit will be still
commercially viable
and we also took the opportunity to
source the building from a local company
who have many years experience of
supplying these lodges in derbyshire
the lodge is built off site which means
that there will be
minimal construction traffic other than
the initial delivery
of the unit to site the holiday inlet
will lead to job creation for someone to
handle the administration and bookings
and the changeover and cleaning
concerns were raised over the smell
produced by the equestrian use of the
site
i can say that the fields have a small
number of ponies grazing them
and in in inclement winter weather or
during very hot weather
they use the stables to provide shelter
from the wet or shade from the sun
any manual produced whilst the ponies
are stable disremoved by trailer from
the site
as this was agreed in the previous
planning for the stables
therefore there is very little smell
arising from the horses
and i think most people would love to be
able to see ponies grazing from their
accommodation
prospective customers will certainly be
advised of this as for many people this
will be a selling point
it is not intended however to allow
guests to bring their own horses
as they question facilities of the pro
or for private use only
as specified in the previously granted
planning permission
with regards to concerns over future
development
as a family we're committed to this site
being maintained
as a green space within the village and
to preserving the unimproved flower rich
hay meadow in the bottom area of the
site 30 seconds remaining
this is an important habitat for many
plants
and animal species and the land is very
different from much of the local
grassland which is
fertilized and sown with single species
protein-rich glass grasses suitable for
cow silage
and therefore lacking in the diversity
which is now so important to the
natural environment i support the
officer's recommendation and hope that
the committee
are also able to approve the proposal
thanks for your time
thank you are there any questions
no questions chad thank you and we have
one more speaker the agent stephen
bright
hello hello thank you chair um
[Music]
i'm uh the agent for mr and mrs cocker
as the time started sorry have you
yes i do beg your pardon i couldn't get
my mic to work so you've got a friend
okay thank you thank you okay um the
proposed development
seeks outline permission for the
provision of a single story two bed log
cabin for holiday-let purposes
on land at new road wingworth the site
forms part of a private equestrian
facility
comprising stabling manage grazing land
and associated uses
the proposed log cabin is a two bed
delayed
with a central living area which will be
provided by
pine log bakewell who supply the same
units on the darwin forest
holiday village near matlock the
original application detailed a three
bed cabin but following concerns that it
was too large
it was revised to a two bed cabin this
reduced the overall size of the unit
from 19.62 meters by 6.42 meters
to 12.3 by 6.8 meters
which also allowed for the proposed
cartilage around the cabin to be
similarly amended
and this parking space has reduced from
three to two
which is in line with the derbyshire
county council requirements for a
two-bed house
the cabins are constructed off-site at
the company's factory
from timber obtained from renewable
sources and the use of a local company
will enhance the sustainability of the
project
the cabin has been designed to sit
within the natural contours of the site
to ensure that it is not visible from
new road
and the retention of existing mature
hedge roads will also provide
additional screening in addition the
timber construction will fit
sympathetically within the site and
complement the existing stable complex
a future reserve matters application
will determine the final appearance of
the log cabin
site layout and landscaping of the
immediate cartilage
we understand from conversations and
information provided by the local
tourist information
center in chesterfield that demand for
this type of holiday accommodation will
be high
due to its location within easy reach of
the peak district national park
and surrounding places of interest in
conclusion
it is considered that the development
will have no detrimental impact on the
area
and provides a satisfactory design
solution which will blend sensitively
within the semi-rural surroundings
we therefore support the officer's
recommendation
and commend the proposal to the
committee for your approval
thank you thank you do we have any
questions
any questions richard thank you
i will move on i'll open the floor to
debate
sorry chair it's any questions to
officers at this point
sorry i was ahead of myself are there
any questions to officers
no questions sure no i'll open the floor
for debate
casa pam winkley chair
sorry nikki councillor windley
thank you chair um
i'm very familiar with this stretch of
roads
um i've been living in the next village
my concern about this is is where
it's going to be and the fact that that
road
is not good the traffic that goes along
there
um is well it's it's awful at times and
the school
is only just a short way down and cars
are parking
to the left-hand side as you're going
down there and
what kind of a turning or turnout would
this
um present i'm wondering for anybody
using
and not familiar with this area
thank you that's my that's my thoughts
thank you i do share some of those
knowing that the parish rooms is
opposite and the traffic on the road
parking on the road um but we're here to
discuss the application and what people
think of it so
if there's no further debate on it oh
hang on councillor armitage
uh thank you chair uh as i look at it
it's uh development
uh in the countryside and it goes
against uh
w-2 of the wingerworth neighbourhood
plan
and also the emerging local
plan of ss9
and it would impact on the
landscape character area
and that's covered in sdc3
i'm not i'm not
happy about it because of all these
things and also
gs6 so that's
my thoughts
any further thoughts
no indications to speak chair
please do
apologies chair there are no members
indicating they wish to speak
thank you there's no other further
questions or
comments we'll move to uh the vote or
the motion
if anyone's prepared to put an emotion
mr roger hall chair yeah
good afternoon was that a motion by uh
william our counselor armitage
no i didn't i believe it was just a
comment
it was a comment okay
as things stand here there is no motion
where do we go from here
[Music]
if there's no motion do i take it that
that then is conditionally passed
chair here you have uh counselor andrew
cooper and councillor maggie jones
wishing to speak
could i move the motion please uh for
officer's recommendations
is that for the rec office's
recommendations councillor cooper yes
that's correct have we seconded for that
i've totally lost the block i think it's
councillor hearts on the second inc
councillor yeah yeah i'll second that
motion
okay
with that i'll hand it over to the
facilitator for rollcall
chair just to confirm that this
is to conditionally approve the
application
if we will uh now commence a roll call
if members could clearly say
fought against or abstain
casa armitage against
casa cooper
sean
i'm just going to give you a prompt to
unmute counselor huckabee
against
casa jones
tesla maggie jones
for
cancer ligit
that's the ligate
just double checking that the mic in the
chamber is working counselor legit
against
how's the power
against
how's the reader four
casa raos
casa rough against
and councillor windley against
okay chair that is five votes four
and eight against with zero abstentions
so the motion
falls
thank you do you think you're having
problems with mike's in here
thank you chair i'll get somebody down
to throw that out for you
was it helpful if i actually read out um
the guidance on motions again just
whilst remember consider the next steps
okay right thanks chair
um please bear in mind members
as you've just seen emotion must be
moved and seconded before a vote is
taken
if an amendment for a motion is moved
and seconded
then the amendment will be voted on
first
if a motion is to be moved which goes
against the officer recommendation
then the member who has moved the motion
must give the reasons for doing so
the reasons for moving a motion against
officer recommendations
should comprise the relevant planning
issues
you you're muted
sorry shirt do apologize shall i just
start again so effectively
just really to tell you that uh if a
motion is to move
which goes against officer
recommendations then the member who has
moved the motion
must give the reasons for doing so the
reasons for moving a motion
against officer recommendations should
comprise the relevant planning issues
and be supported by the evidence as
necessary
if a motion to reject officer
recommendations fails
or in other words is not passed that
doesn't make
the recommendation are automatically
approved
rather you will need to take a positive
decision through a further motion
in favor of the recommendations or
another course of action
this will need to be approved by the
committee to do another vote
thank you chair thank you
so i take we are okay with where we've
passed
now we can move on to the next
application
no decisions being taken on this right
okay
okay the proposal and seconding the
motion has
has failed but there's now it needs uh
to be a
new proposition for forward
council armitage i see your hands up
yeah uh
i would go against officers
recommendation
uh and the reasons being are
uh it's against
and w2 uh
also development in the countryside uh
and that's to do with the winger hood
neighborhood
plan so those are my reasons
thank you do we have a seconder i'll
i'll second it thank you roger
can we now have a roll call for a vote
yeah so as i understand
um essentially it's to um reject um
the application against officer
recommendations on the grounds of
inappropriate development in the
countryside
is that the essence of it i'm not sure
if you want to say anything
richard yeah i was just going to say
that
tourism related development in the
countryside
um is an acceptable form of development
um and in this particular case it is
probably the
the uh least impactful source of um
tourism development that uh that would
be uh that is being proposed
so i think you you need to be
identifying some
very specific um reason
as to why this particular
involvement is unacceptable in this
particular location as opposed to simply
believing that the um
is for this country to um it's an
appropriate development in the
countryside
right okay
i'm thinking it uh goes against uh
the landscape character of sdc3
also
counselor on that point if we look at
the report on 7.4
it says policy 11 uh states that the
proposals for new tourist accommodation
in countryside locations
um where will be permitted where they
involve the reuse
and conversion of existing buildings or
extension
of existing tourist facilities only so
it would seem to me that this isn't a
reunion
um of an existing building or a
convention
i agree with that uh council poll
that's uh policy eleven i think as
you'll see
in in the uh subsequent policy um
it's considered that that is a an
out-of-date uh policy
but um and i'd emphasize that uh
the need to identify a particular
characteristic where this is harmful in
this particular location
well i think it is harmful in this
particular
location
so as things stand to the
motion is to move against officer
recommendations
and reject the application on the
grounds that he has
a harmful impact on the surrounding
countryside area is that the essence of
it
at the moment i believe so is that
correct cancer armitage
yeah that's correct yeah thank you
can we have a seconder the second it was
councillor hall
are you still comfortable with that
counselor yeah yeah i'm happy with it
thank you can we then move to the vote
if members can say for against or
abstain
for rejection of the application council
armitage
or counselor cooper
against
council huckabee
councillor huckabee
i'll just pop a prompt in your script
there you are you you are muted
uh against
councillor jones gaines
council liggett
how's the lig we're not able to hear you
through that mic
severe problems with microphones before
casa powell
how's the power you're muted
cancer reader
against but can i just say before we
took the vote i indicated twice that i
wanted to speak before we went to this
vote
so i'm really disappointed that i wasn't
picked up
i apologize council reader but you're
just in a black void for us at this site
this end of the screen
i've indicated to the facilitator as
well that i wanted to speak twice and
i've been ignored both times
my apologies to you council reader i did
miss that indication
chair would you like me to can you
continue with the vote yes please
casa raos
against
chair that is five votes four seven
against with one abstention
and that motion falls
right where do we go from here well as
things stand uh
um the application is not determined
okay sorry counselor reader
chair counselor thank you
what i was going to say before we took
the phone is we need to be mindful that
this is an
outline planning application
i also know that stretch of road having
traveled it very
very often to get into work
i'm not certain of of how much traffic
just uh people on holiday would create
just from from that one lodge um
you know the bookings will probably be
controlled
uh by the applicant or whoever they put
into place
and it's two bedrooms so i'm assuming
that would
mean only probably two car movements so
i'm not 100 sure that that would create
too much really and not unnecessary
traffic
but i believe because it's an outline
planning application we have the
opportunity here
to set down what our concerns are
and let the applicant know that and and
go back and work on it if we really need
to
in order to move this forward
counselor jones
yeah i put hand up earlier as well and
it was
the same kind of reasons but also when
we did the site visit
which was on virtual um it was stated
that it can't really be seen from the
road
so i don't think it's going to make a
big impact on the
countryside in that area and as
counselor reader said if it's just a
small family
to a bedroomed accommodation it's not
going to be an awful lot of extra
traffic
so is there a new motion
[Music]
can i put a motion then is that we defer
this for further consultation
could someone second that motion yeah
i'll second that chair
thank you can we show have a roll call
now please nikki course
yeah um i've got a number of members
putting hands up is that
for a show of hands or wanting to speak
i just mean
counsellor huckabee yes chair
um i'm just wondering what the purpose
of the deferment
would serve um if you could explain that
for me
we seem to be a locker head so i'm just
wondering if we could have the
application tightened up and the
concerns that have been raised
addressed and submitted back to the the
committee
otherwise i think we're just going to be
going around around in circles
counselor wingley yeah thanks chair
um i commented on on the road
um it wasn't so much as
um the residents that or the holiday
makers that would be using the lodge
it was more of worthy i i think
the entrance and exit is to come out
of that that that was my concerns when i
mentioned how busy
it can get on that road
so just to clarify that was my my
meaning
on that is the um entrance and exit
opposite that junction
no it's to the right um if you come up
to the right
yeah if you're coming out of long edge
lane it's to the right of the junction
if you're coming up with hill houses it
would be to the left
yes yeah yeah so it's in quite a busy
area as they're coming in and going out
yes
thank you yeah that was my point i was
making not about
how many cars would be going in and out
of there
thank you hey you've got an indication
from emily cartwright the planning
officer on this
and uh tracy reader council tracy would
wishes to speak
okay um emily
can i just clarify with councillor
windley please
yes certainly thank you councillor
and it's an existing access so there
would be no
new access it's just that would be
intensified by
the holiday laps which would have
absolutely two bedrooms and highways
have raised no concerns regarding this
right thank you thank you
counselor reader yeah could i just ask
the planning officers
um because it is outline is there any
possibility
of addressing some of the concerns that
counsellors have
now today with the applicant if they're
willing
rather than deferring the application
i think we do need to identify what
the concerns are in relation to the
matter of principle which is what an
outline application
needs to establish i mean we do have
knowledge that this is going to be a um
a log
cabin um so there's not a lot of sort of
design um
issues uh that still need to be um
be determined although yes there are the
actual details of that um
uh of that copy that cabin that we need
to
um that we'll need to see but it's not
um
uh there's not a lot of um
uh great scope of um range of designs
that would be there that we might think
are unacceptable or acceptable
um given that uh
we can be pretty sure that it's going to
be
a have a bit more design quality to it
than the stables that are there for
instance
um in terms of the access i think
um that point is now just being cleared
up in as much as
um it has been just confirmed that it is
the
uh the same access we're talking about
um
uh people coming in and out from there
in probably the most minimal numbers of
uh
vehicles that could be possible for such
a
development um
it's difficult to see what more
additional
information um certainly from the debate
that we've had so far
uh could really be um
needed if it was going to be deferred
but clearly we've had a proposal to
grant planning permission and the
proposal to refuse planning permission
both of which have been
have been lost um so it really
is in your gift to try and
illuminate us as to what your concerns
are and what's specifically more
information
you feel is needed and would be
the purpose of a deferral
check has the heart shaun's indicating
his wish to speak
counselor hearts on uh thank you jeff um
as i see it um i don't really see that
we've got any grounds to refuse this
um it's an outline application
we're wanting to generate a a visit to
strategy
within the area and then we're going to
kick this out
you know we want to be bringing money
into the area not
just dismissing it thank you
thank you council reader yeah i think i
have to agree i think it's
very it's like councillor jones was
saying it's screened from the main area
it's trying to in keep with the fact
that it's in the countryside it's going
to be of a log presentation which
indicates wood to me so which is
in you know indicative of a countryside
feel
i think the movements around how many
people are going to be there is minimal
because
it's a holiday let so
it's two bedrooms so you're probably
going to be looking at a maximum of four
people
um which is probably just either one or
two cars
i think it's an existing access which
you've addressed already
through through what we've been
discussing that it's an existing access
i don't know how many ponies are kept on
that site but i'm guessing there'll be
vehicle movements already going into
that site
so i can't see where there would be any
highways issues
so um chair i i kind of i'm at a loss
of of why we would be refusing it i'm
very similar to councillor arts on
okay are there any other comments on
this councilor pal
i would just suggest uh through the
chair um
that any one or two of the seven people
who voted against
the last um would be invited to
propose a new one which is more in line
with what they've been thinking
well just in terms of that uh i've just
had a message uh
from um jim i think we might actually
now be in a position
where we'll need to um suspend council
procedure rules
in order to actually vote again
yeah so if i if i can speak um
this is this isn't the first time where
we've been in this situation where we've
had a
um proposal to uh to grant permission
refused
and then a proposal to um refuse
planning
planning commission and turn down uh on
the same
application um so what we had to
what you what you can't normally do in
accordance with council procedure rules
is vote on the same matter
at the same meeting however in order to
get around that
what you can do is suspend council
procedure rules and then you
which would enable you to then um take
a have a further motion on the uh on
either to grant or refuse planning
permission and then take a vote in
in a normal way so you would need to
before you do that you would need to
take a vote as to whether to suspend
council procedure rules to enable you to
uh to proceed
thank you are we all in agreement to
move that we
uh suspend these meeting the rules
nikki williams consensus
did you raise your hands for
forever chair and all the members
voting remotely have voted for
suspension
i'm sorry nikki i didn't hear that all
the members voting remotely voted for
suspension of the council procedure
rules so it's just yourself and
councillor leggett
four
we're both sharing some a mic we've
still got issues but don't
there we go okay my apologies so that
would be carried to suspend council
procedure rules chair
okay so now we need another motion put
forward
oh this is ridiculous
chair signs counselor reader
would it be possible to move off of
officers recommendations to approve the
application
um it you know i think we do need to
move this on
i can't see honestly where there is an
issue
with this and so i would move officer's
recommendations please
have we a seconder for this motion
councillor cooper uh yes sir i've been
having
um moved the motion initially then i'm
happy to second
council reader's motion um i've not
heard anything
like council reader that's made my
change my mind
in fact anything else it's reaffirmed
exactly what i thought in the first
place so
i'm not sure why we're looking to turn
this down actually so
yes i'll second the motion thank you
nikki can we have a vote now please
of course so just to be clear the vote
uh the motion is to approve
officer recommendations to approve the
planning application
thank you if members quickly say full
against or abstain
armitage against
cancer cooper or cancer foster
or catholic
abstain how's the heart sean
casa huckabee
just to confirm council liggett that was
against
castle powell
casarida four
castlevals
castle buff abstain
castle windley
casa wendy
against
chair with eight votes four three
against
and two abstentions that motion is
carried
thank you all very much
and we'll we can move on to the next
application
which is four two zero four slash zero
zero
five zero six four slash tpo
this is the application for removal of
41.
popular is covered by tpo number six in
various stages of decline
excuse me and this is old topton
the officer would like to give their
presentation
thank you chair um
just to let you know there was a late
representation
uh from a mr muldoon uh which was sent
out in the late reps
uh two members yesterday
nikki are you okay to do the
presentation
thank you so this is an application to
file 41 poplars which are in a very
which are in various stages of decline
due to their age
location and health have the next slide
please
the trees are located on the anchor bowl
road
site which has permission for 193
dwellings
they're on the boundary with the
dwellings known as the poplars and the
gables
the trees are covered by an area tpo
and a partner group a1 of the neddc tp06
which was made in 1980
next slide please
the area tpo runs from the road to the
east for approximately 100 meters
westwards
it is approximately 20 meters wide
a hedge runs below the area of trees to
the south and forms the boundary with
the poplars and the gables
this hedge is not subject to tpo indeed
hedges cannot be subject to tpos
the tpo protects trees which make a
significant contribution to the amenity
of the area
next slide please
now this slide shows uh the trees when
viewed from inside the development site
i can have the next slide please
a tree survey was commissioned by the
applicant in
2019 this class the group of trees is
category c
low quality next slide please
the reasons for removal have been given
that the 41 poplars are in poor
condition
and decline and have considerable
amounts of dead wood in the crown and
are showing signs of canker
next slide please
um the council's parks officer agrees
with this assessment
and these photos show that the trees are
not in best condition
the arborio cultural association
guidance suggests that the average
natural life of
couplers is around 50 to 70 years
it's likely that these trees were at
least 10 to 20 years old when
they were tpo'd which makes them around
50 to 60 years old now
they are therefore likely to be coming
to the end of their natural life
next slide please
the applicant proposes to replace the
trees with 14 specimens of mixed mostly
native species
such as field maple oak lime birch and a
few poplars
the justification for replacement with
fewer trees as is that these species
have a lower
wider shape and therefore need more
space to thrive
these species have been suggested by the
parks officer
as they should be longer lived in the
poplars and by providing a mixture of
native species
will add to the biodiversity of the site
the parks officer is in agreement with
the quantity and layout proposed
next slide please
you can see that the trees are prominent
when viewed from anchor bold road
and the next slide please
however their condition reduces their
attractiveness
and therefore their immunity next slide
this just shows them again from anchor
bold road
and then the next slide please thank you
this aerial photo shows that the trees
do help to screen the anchorball road
development site from the gables and the
poplars
next
this photo shows the trees to the north
of the entrance to the gables and the
poplars
so that's the entrance just there
and the next slide please it is officers
view
that whilst there may be short-term
impact on the neighbours as a result of
the loss of the trees
the new planting coupled with proposed
management of this hedge
approved in the landscaping scheme for
the development site
will mitigate the impact
next slide please again this
slide shows that the trees are not in
good shape
there may be a short-term impact on
biodiversity due to the loss of trees
however this will be mitigated by the
long-term improvement
as a result of the introduction of a
mixture of native trees to the area
the replacement trees will be around 3
to 3.5 metres high
and have a girth of 10-12 centimeters
these have been agreed by the tree
officer as being a suitable trade-off
between providing young trees of a size
which will mitigate the loss of mature
trees
and ensuring they're able to survive the
move to this location
the replacement trees will be covered by
the tpo
the applicant has indicated that they
intend to plant more trees
outside of the area covered by the tpo
but because this is an
area tpo rather than a woodland one it
is not possible to condition the
planting of replacement or additional
trees
outside of the area however if this tpo
application is allowed
an application to vary the landscaping
condition of the planning permission
for the development will have to be
submitted and any further tree planting
along with additional management of the
hedge will be included in this
um so the remaining photos further
illustrate the location visibility and
condition of the trees and
taking into account the information
above
is considered that the proposal is
acceptable and officers are recommending
approval
thank you chair
thank you are there any questions
i can't see anybody on the screen at
this present time oh there we go
are there any questions for the officer
no members indicating chad well you did
well alice
okay and we're moving on to the speakers
and we've got representation from both
ward members david hancock and ross
shipman
i believe we've got their statements to
be read out
uh councillor and david hancock's now
um in the meeting and so be able to read
his own statement
thank you thank you councillor hancock
thank you chair i have numerous concerns
in regard to this application most
significantly in regards to the impact
removal of these trees will have on
local biodiversity
i've already questioned the legitimacy
of contradictory reports which have been
used to justify this application versus
that which was all
which was originally submitted at the
very least i would urge members to defer
any decision pending a wholly
independent report
excuse me a wholly independent report
being provided given the planning
authority's vested financial interest in
this development
any reports submitted by the parks
department no matter how much faith we
have in the integrity of individual
officers
cannot in any meaningful sense be
considered not to be a conflict of
interest
as members will appreciate even trees in
a state of decay are vital to an area's
biodiversity
and should only legitimately be removed
where they present a
threat to safety only two weeks ago i
was taken on a tour of the perimeter of
this site by the project manager
and there is absolutely no evidence of
that being the case
i also wish to take issue with our
planning officers who in their report
have attempted to dismiss my concerns
about flooding as irrelevant
that is a complete distraction as even
an infant is aware of the vital role
that trees play in water absorption and
flood mitigation
the attempt to divert the planning
committee's attention from such a vital
function is a huge concern
and i urge members to use their own
common sense when assessing that aspect
disruption of wildlife is inevitable
inevitability of building works
and over the past few weeks the site
clearance has had a devastating impact
on what was one of the main centers of
wildlife in my ward
hedgehogs foxes badges bats and birds
were all frequent visitors to
neighboring gardens along wingfield road
station new road and anchorball road
visits from the land mammals have
reduced to almost nothing over the past
few weeks
removal of these trees on mass as
proposed will destroy the habitats of
what little remains committee also needs
to look at the long-term future the
applicant is proposing to replace 41
trees with just 14
a reduction of almost two-thirds aside
from the obvious impact on wildlife and
the sustainability of natural habitat
it will have a significant impact on the
immunity of those neighboring pro of
those existing neighboring properties
and those that they're proposing to
erect there is no possible winner in
this scenario
beyond saving development
our wildlife habitat existing residents
and those will ultimate who will
ultimately move into the new homes will
all be poori should this application be
removed
i therefore urge members to reject
officer recommendations
and to agree only to the removal of any
trees which absolutely
need to be removed on health and safety
grounds following a truly independent
assessment from an organization
financial interest that's that's me
complete thank you nikki
thank you councillor are there any
questions
no thank you we'll move on to councillor
shipman's
letter yes thank you chair i'll read it
out now
i would like to state that i object to
all 41 trees being removed from this
location
as part of this planning application
members should be drawn to the tree
survey conducted on 19th november 2020
i think that's a mistake which states
only 4 out of 41 trees
are dead in line with the district
council decision to amend the planning
application in holy moorside for similar
reasons only a few weeks ago
i believe this application should only
be approved for four trees to be removed
and for four additional trees to be
planted elsewhere on the site to replace
them
the remaining 37 trees should remain
and the planning committee can then have
the opportunity to review
any planning application in the future
to remove any more
this would ensure that the planning
committee is consistent in its approach
to removing trees
protected by tree preservation orders in
northeast derbyshire
that's the end of the statement sir
thank you
thank you and i believe we've got one
more
late representation is that to be read
out or was that just included in the
pack
uh that was included in the pack uh
chair but it's a matter for yourself as
you wish
um the officers to read it out
yes please and that way we've also okay
if you just bear with me one second
[Music]
yes this is the statement uh from a mr
muldoon
um and it's in your reports a lakepak
representations reported page four as
neighbor comments
and the statement is as follows i'm
concerned that the application
has not given any uh the applicant has
not given any valid reason for the
removal of these 41 trees
other than a supposition that they have
assumed that the risk is high
when only two years ago they were
classified as viable
to remain under the protection of the
original tpo
in my humble opinion the only reason
reasonable way to determine the trees
to determine the trees are so far
diseased is to take a sample number say
a maximum of 10 percent to be felled
and photographed by an independent
witness and a decision then taken
on the rest if it is decided to remove
all of the trees then the felling should
be witnessed by photograph
and recorded so as to hold to task
anyone
who should be proved to be wrong on the
assumption
the government policy is to plant trees
not to fell established ones
that are under tpos it is apparent that
one of the reasons to fail these trees
is that other than if proved dangerous
it will be more difficult to sell the
properties
with the trees subject to tpo within the
cartilage
of the residence this is good reason
why any replacement trees should also be
given tpo status
should the application be approved
whether replacements not to be
restricted by tpo
the owners could fell as they pleased
the existing established established
trees and hedgerows our bounty are a
bountiful source of wildlife
with a varied number of different bird
and bat species
and should be retained if possible
enough trees have already been removed
off the la
on the land opposite this application
with reckless abandon
and will probably never be replaced uh i
have
not seen a planting plan that includes
the replanting of oak elm chestnut
silver birch to name but a few
of the ones felled by the applicant
prior to the work starting on the site
we had fox badger and numerous rabbits
and several hedgehogs
in our garden we have seen none of these
since the hedgerows and trees have been
removed
we should be protecting fauna and
wildlife not causing their extinction
please reject this application and
that's the end of the statement chair
thank you
there's no more speakers so this is now
the opportunity
for questions to the planning manager
and officers about the application
again i'd like to keep this part of our
proceedings focused on getting clarity
about any points that you are not sure
of
once we have done this we can then have
our discussion about the application
based on all we've heard and read that
reasons members i will continue to be
grateful if you could not move any
emotions at this stage
let's wait until we've all had a chance
to make our assessments
again the same rules apply please make
your mics
unless you wish to speak thank you
are there any is indicating her wish to
speak
please go ahead thank you chair
um it's about the trees and the co the
conflict that we seem to have in
opinions of these trees
there was a survey that we were um
submitted um in may 2019
and it gives a different opinion of the
conditions of the trees
to the one in july 2020 after the
builders had
gone back in and i'm just wondering why
this is
why suddenly all 41
need to come down whereas only last year
it that wasn't the case
we've already lost as other people have
said
a lot of the ground wildlife and
hedgehogs
particularly which are dwindling have
gone down to nothing
the hedgerows have been ripped out and
the hedgehogs
just scooped up and chucked wherever
that's not right
and now there is is the fact that um
boundaries and to headrose and
for residents are being taken out this
needs proper consultation and that's not
right either
we're going to lose a lot of birds it's
not that long since i looked up
horse guys and i'm on wingfield road to
see a harris hawk
gliding across that's not something that
we've been seeing in tuckton
and this is all of thanks to the avenue
washlands
those trees down there will be providing
a nesting place for some of these birds
that we've now got coming
so i'm just wondering why this
this conflict is of the
time scale of the trees and i agree with
what's being said before
that they should have an independent
assessment somebody else needs to go in
there
and look at it again and at least then
we may have a clearer indication
and if that indication is yeah there to
go then
that that's fine as long as they're
replaced by
all the trees that's going to give the
same kind of security to the wildlife
thank you
would you like me to address some of
these points john yes please if you
would
okay um just starting with the point
that
uh council winley um mentioned but it's
also the starting point that
uh for council hancock and that was in
relation to contradictory reports
um but my understanding of
the difference between a tree survey
originally
carried out and now is that
since um outline planning information
has been granted and start to
look at the implementation of the um
of the scheme but uh they they're
realizing that really these trees
are going to be far more difficult to
manage when there are trees
so when there are houses built on the
other side than they are
they are now but certainly um they are
going to be
um uh in in needing within the next
few years at least um to
to to have serious management or removal
the original proposal was to do
some um uh pruning and
to slowly take them out but this felt
that really
grabbing the ball by the horns here and
doing all the work
and then um giving the maximum period of
time
for the new trees to become established
rather than doing it slowly
is the best way of
approaching this the the second point
that um uh that has been raised one of
councillor
hancock's point the local planning
authority
is all people around this table
around the screen um and
the local planning authority's role is
to make a decision
in relation to the application that is
before them
um the local planning authority does not
have a
um a financial interest in
um in these trees coming out or not
the local planning authority needs to
make a balanced decision in relation to
the trees
the issue relating to the trees and the
flooding um
during the course of this development
and once completed
the entire hydrology of this field
will change and it will become more of a
managed
hydrology and drainage scheme and and
and so
um that will have a big impact
on um water movement across the the site
it's not a case of saying that um uh
it's a
it's a um red herring in relation to
these these trees clearly these trees
are deteriorating and
the the faster they deteriorate
the um the less impact they will have
in terms of absorbing water from the
from the ground
and so having new trees planted which
are going to then
um require a good water a good
moisture level in the soil to be able to
grow
will actually have an improved
situation in relation to that particular
part of the site's
ability to to hold water and for those
trees to actually make the most of that
water
i think as um uh alice has uh
mentioned in her own um introduction
there
there will be a a short term uh
reduction in the amount of habitat
in in that area because of the work that
they're doing
but the um the bolstering the thickening
of the um of the hedge there and
as the new trees of a um a species that
is
uh uh more able to
support wildlife that that will start to
come back
and clearly the sooner that those trees
are in and being able to grow to
um to maturity um
the better and yes there could well be
an element of loss of privacy until
those trees start to build
that canopy but um again
the sooner these are put in the sooner
this
um impact will be experienced
there was mentioned to the recent holy
moorside
application and um
members will be aware that really every
application
must be considered on its own know it
but also
when it comes to trees the
the individual health of a tree
and its own uh particular ecology in
that area and the own
its own context it will be unique
and so you need to be very cautious
about saying well
um it came to a balanced decision uh a
holy moore side there could be a
balanced decision here
we must be looking at uh this
application in its entirety for
for trying to make the decision and the
final
uh point was as mentioned of
giving approval for the removal of four
dead trees and having replanted
trees but um required to be put
in you don't need
listed building sorry the tree
preservation order consent
to remove
data trees if trees are dead you could
just take them down without
the need for for that consent anyway so
so this is really
yes there may well be some uh
totally dead trees within these 41 but
they're looking at removing
all of them as a group and some of them
may not actually need to be
given that sort of consent if they are
actually dead
i think that's answered all the points
that i've i've
i thought needed to be answered
councillor liggett um richard
um it says park did parks department
comments
can you tell me exactly which person
went out to
assess these trees
um i i can't give you uh that's a
precise
officer but um we do rely on the
um parks department for uh for
inspection of
um uh of trees and as in due course
we'll be having
wanted to have our own uh expertise
within the planning department but
um that would be to supplement the the
advice that we get from
from the parks officers um
you happened to bring up holly moore's
side and i asked then who'd been out and
i was told i can't remember the lady's
second name but kate
somebody and i checked afterwards and
apparently kate sorry i can't remember
her surname
is actually street scene co-ordinator
she has absolutely nothing to do with
trees and that was the lady who had
assessed the holy moorside trees
and that is why this worries me and i
feel very strongly
that if tpos are put on trees then it
should be a tpo
officer that goes and says if trees need
to be taken down
chair you have indications to speak from
council's armitage windley and
powell we'll take them in that order
councillor heritage first
thank you chair i
listened to the uh
reasoning from the uh planning officer
which i don't accept at all
uh i'm qualified uh
well i went to university and one of the
uh
courses i did was on forestry and
forestry management
and i've since been on various courses
to keep me up to date
the latest one i went was a a course
by dalk on uh tree management
what you don't realize is this when you
put
a poplar tree for a start it's a pretty
dangerous
tree you can't use the
usual root management and root
protection area
for a poplar the route go for miles
well not for miles let's see
30 40 feet outside
what is the recognized route protection
area
and as a result if you perform near a
building
uh you're going to get the route coming
up
in the middle of your dining room or
undermining walls or under
damaging drainage pipes and for that
reason uh the
you have to allow for this and it will
result
in a number of houses less on these
sites
now i've seen this on a number of places
where a uh application is granted
you put the they think the buildings on
the plan
right up to the extremities the result
is
after a few weeks they come back
and they say oh uh could we have
permission to prune
or can we take it away we saw this
i've seen it in october and i've seen it
uh
only uh the last time at holy mall side
we come up with all the excuses now
we have tpos to protect the build the
area
and here we have 41 not all 41 are going
to be
past it you know when we're talking
average ages
50 to 70 years old well
you know i'm 70 years old and i'm not
past it and it's time you took notice of
people who know about
trees and not by uh street seen people
who you're going to have with asked for
uh
an independent report and we need an
independent report
we mentioned about the hedgehogs and the
wildlife
did you take any notice of debbie
attenborough's uh
recall saying that in so many years by
2050 50 of the wildlife will be killed
when did you last see a hedgehog
i saw one the other day in my garden
it's the first i've seen
for years literally they used to be on
the side of the road splattered
you never see one now because they've
all been destroyed
and the biggest factor was uh that was
destroyed there was a motor car
let's say uh about the hawks
hawks like to go in big tall trees like
a poplar
we've had a decline at the foothawk
population
has declined we've blamed everything
else
apart from the habitat we've got the
other habitats
of foxes and things like that what
happens
you derive them out of the countryside
because you are destroying the habitat
in which they're living and the result
is
that uh they end up in people's gardens
pulling dustbins out killing somebody's
cat
or somebody's rabbit please
just think again we don't want to be
destroying
our habitat for the environment and
that's what you're doing
by allowing people to take down uh
trees which are covered by a gpo the tpo
was put there for a reason
to conserve it and please take notice of
it thank you councillor reader
chair you had indications to speak from
councillors windley
and powell um lee hartshorn and maggie
jones
councillor windley
thank you chair um it's it's actually
just
to um go back to the
graph that we've been submitted from the
tree
survey in 2019 when
um the recording was 20 fair
20 good and too poor
and the contribution um which i'm taking
was the contribution
to the to the land and the length of
time
was were 31 trees and considered lung
so again i go back to why
um it suddenly only 12
40 months on they all need cutting down
there there is still an if you look at
that graph that's what it says on the
graph
there and i have concerns i do really
think that
we need it to be looked at again to be
reassessed
thank you chair thank you move on to the
next speaker counselor hearthstone
thank you chair yeah i've just got a
question for richard a couple of
questions for richard um
uh will the um we've obviously got this
area that's covered by a tpo
um will that form
part of the garden of individual houses
when this development's complete that's
my first question
and the other question is is why you've
agreed
to accept this when we've got foot um
with a replacement of only 14 trees
and the destruction of 41.
such a massive reduction in trees it's
um i can't understand why that's been
accepted
thank you thank you
i'll i'll let some
uh let's get onto the screen the um
the the layout again um with um uh
nikki's assistance in in a minute uh to
show you
the layout and um to confirm that
these are these would be within
um the back gardens of um of some of
those trees
of some of those houses um and then
there'll be
uh there are a few down at the far end
which are in a small area of open space
what i um
what i would say is that and again alex
did touch on this in her presentation
is that um the
the form of poplar trees is very
uh colonial very upright and therefore
um in terms of the uh sort of air space
that they
they need is not as not as broad
as would be the case with um an oak
horse chestnut or something like that
so um the
the that that is the reason why we have
such a difference between
41 um taken out and 14
being replaced and
of course with um the
uh the movement or the
direction of lifespan of these
existing trees four may well be dead
at the moment but that is the direction
that these trees are going to be headed
in by the time
all of them have died we could have had
in place
um another 10 or 15 years of growth
of trees that are going to be there to
replace them
and and so that's that's another factor
to um to
to bear in mind but just one final point
i think
if um if the committee does feel
in doubt about
the
department and from the applicant's own
our body culturist
such that an independent um
advice needs to be obtained
then and you wanted to defer it for that
reason
then that is that's a um
it's not an unprecedented uh um
line to take
thank you any other speakers
councillor powell chair councillor pal
um can i just say that aside that i am
very disappointed
um that one of the speakers has
um impugned the reputation and integrity
of one of our own offices
by claiming a conflict of interest i
think that
is seriously disappointing and
somebody asked for the name of that
individual i think that name should not
be made public
thank you counselor pal so noted
are there any other apologies chair
counselor jones was indicating her wish
to speak
councillor jones where's your concealer
she is yes thank you chair um
you know this derbyshire district
council
we've already um said about climate
change and how it's a priority for us
and climate change that is offset by
trees mature trees now i was very upset
to hear the first part of the
presentation the word attractiveness
it's not about attractiveness it's about
maturity and that what they're doing to
the atmosphere
are aiding us and we need to be looking
after
mature trees as well as planting lots
and lots more
trees not taking any down
um and the habitat
yeah exactly we're now losing loads of
animals
the whole world is changing and do we
want that as an inheritance for our
children
no we don't so can't we just
forget about attractiveness let the
trees grow
plant more trees as they die off we can
replant with something different that's
going to be more
in line with british
whatever but i just think taking down 41
trees is
really something i could never ever
support
thank you thank you
you have two indications to speak
council halls and councillor foster
hello yeah good afternoon uh in order to
try and move
progress could i suggest as it's already
been advised to us that we can
uh ask for another independent
uh uh report on the trees
and defer this please
okay thank you we have one other speaker
then we'll move on that
where is he i can't see them
how's the foster wish to speak chair
counselor foster uh thank you chair
uh i'm no expert on trees at all unlike
some people on here
uh so i tend to do is trust the
information that's been put in front of
me
and uh i've trusted what
uh alice lockett said and i trust the
the park office's opinion uh that it's
accurate because that's that's what we
do we trust the information is in front
of us
uh that's not to say that if people on
here have got
real doubts about them that i wouldn't
support
um an independent uh review of the trees
but as it stands i would trust what's
written here
that the life of the trees uh for
poplars
uh is 50 to 70 years old these are
already 50 to 60 years old many
in poor condition i can see the
condition of the trees
uh for myself just looking at this
report from what i've heard from
from his lucky for me i'd be taking
advantage
and getting the new trees planted and
especially as they could
be covered by tpo as well that in
conjunction with them being native
species
and although the poplar is a
naturalized species it's not a native
species um
so that's the way i'm inclined to go
that we take advantage we get these uh
these native uh mature trees that can uh
can take the place of
these old dying trees um if they are in
that condition and that's me trusting
what
um the parks department
have said so that would be my view i'd
be happy to follow the
uh office's recommendations but hey i'm
i'm no expert in trees often i've cut
down a few
thank you we have now
got a emotion on the table but first of
all i'd like the clerk to go
through the correct procedure for a
motion
now chair as things stand at the moment
we've had two suggestions for motions i
don't think actually either have
been seconded
thank you um councillor hall has put on
a recommendation
for a motion that we defer this for an
independent review
is there a seconder for this
seconded by councillor liggett
if i we will now have to take a vote on
that i believe that's correct
yeah so essentially the motion appears
to be to refer
uh in order to get um further
independent advice
uh on the state of the trees so that a
decision can then be taken
is that the essence of a chair i do
believe so
is that correct counselor hall yeah
yes that that's correct to defer it and
then get
further um advice or a survey or report
on them thank you thank you
so we now have a motion to put forward
before that
council of foster's indicating to speak
councillor foster thanks chair i do
appreciate you let me come in there
um we'll get more of these in the future
can we make sure that we
that we do monitor this and see what
comes back and see how it compares to
our own parks department comments so is
there a possibility chair that
that this could this issue could be
brought back
uh i know this case will be brought back
this application will be brought back
but can we make sure that we get a
chance to discuss this so we can compare
these independent comments because what
i'm fearful of is that
in future this becomes a standard thing
that if people don't want trees cut down
they'll ask for
an independent uh view and it'll take
the faith of people uh perhaps residents
perhaps counsellors away from
what our parks department is doing and
it's their job to do that
so what i don't want to do is reveal the
faith that i have
in our offices and the job they do and
what i don't want to do is encourage
this
each time one comes up that people
object to that's every time you've
gotten a
one's got an objection against trees
being cut down we call for an
independent it's going to cost
the council a lot of money and we have
to be careful about what money we spend
and how we spend it
so let's bring this this issue back uh
and we actually look at
it i don't know for planning if we can
add it onto a planning agenda
and we can compare what exactly what is
done and then in future we can have
faith in those
officers recommendations because we
don't want this happening each time
and also at the echo council powell's
comments we don't bring
individual officers uh into this public
meeting and question their uh
question their their judgment that's
this is not the place
thank you thank you um
that's something which just will help um
um
just take what council fosters just said
a bit further
um we have recently
um had approval from covernet to um
recruit a a planning authority
um our boy culture is on a part on a
a part-time basis what we get from
the parks team um
i believe is is fine as far as it goes
but it is an informal arrangement with
them and there are cases
such as this one such as some other
cases that you'll all be familiar with
where far more detailed information
and more time needs to be given to these
things and that's where we feel that we
need to have our own
in-house resource uh to be able to
dedicate to that rather than rely on
uh on the part team i think the parks
team are
are brilliant in being able to give us
um those initial assessments
but i think that one they don't have the
time to give to give
us what we really need for for some of
the more complicated ones and so
we are going to be in the process of um
recruiting our own
internal expert for all that and of
course as
a local planning authorities are
polyculturists
that is really as i would see it as
being
an independent professional
thank you i'm sure we can take that
forward um
mark i think it's quite an important
issue and you're right we don't need to
keep going round and round in circles
every time one comes back
so we will take that on board so we have
got the motion
forwarded um by council hall and
seconded by
councillor liggett to postpone this
hearing until we've had an independent
review
so that's an independent assessment to
the health and viability of the trees
that's the one yeah okay
thank you there's no further comment
nikki i'd like to go to the vote thank
you chair
um so i will um go through in order
of alphabetical order if you could
indicate poor against or abstain
cancer armitage counselor cooper
or cancer foster
four that's the hall
council heart sean oh
councillor huckabee
councillor huckabee thor
castle jones for counselor liggett
councillor powell casarida
four that's 13 votes four chairs are
against zero abstentions that's carried
so the consideration of the application
has been deferred
yes thank you for an independent
any chance of just a five minute break
quickly you may certainly
yes no problem if we're back here by
3 50 very latest please
remember if you'd be kind enough just to
meet yourselves and turn your cameras
off
um until you're back in the room
jay you're back live thank you
for our last application of this
afternoon is
um two zero four slash zero zero one
six six forward slash zero l
this is the outline application all
matters reserved for the erection of one
detached dwelling affecting
the setting of the listed building at
land between
overton lodge and brookside cottage at
milltown ashover
over to the planning officer
thank you chad could get the slides
please nichola
it's just doing that for you now thank
you
thank you this outline application all
matters reserved
is for the erection of one detached
dwelling next slide please
the application site is located to the
west of jetting street between overton
lodge and brookside cottage and is
highlighted in
orange here the application site is
located
outside of any defined settlement
development limit
and is designated as a special landscape
area
it is also cited within stars wood and
milton
milltown quarry which is a special
designated local wildlife
site click the next slide please
this slide shows the location plan the
application site is identified by the
red line
to the west of jetting street which
doubles up as a public right of way
and bride away to the east lies the
river amber and a further public right
of way
we have the next one please thank you
this slide shows an indicative block
plan of the proposed dwelling
this shows the dwelling to be positioned
to the north of the plot and fronting
onto jetting street with offering
parking spaces for two vehicles to the
side
have the next one please
this slide shows an indicative
cross-section of the proposed dwelling
as you can see from this
the dwelling front onto jetting street
to the east
and the land slopes up steeply to the
west significant
excavation works would be required we
have the next slide please
this slide shows an indicative floor
plan of the proposed three-bedroom
dwelling
moving on to the photos thank you
this photo is taken from jetting street
looking straight on at the proposed site
as you can see the site has been cleared
apart from a handful of trees
it is noted that none of these trees
were protected by a tpo
to the top of the photo is the
neighboring listed building known as
common bank house
this is sited in an elevated position
approximately 30 meters away from the
proposed welling
have the next slide please thank you
this very time to take it from along
jetting street outside the neighboring
property
one out and large in the background is
the neighboring property brookside
cottage as you can see there is a good
level of screening between this dwelling
and the site
have the next one please thank you
this photo is also taken from along
jetting street but outside the
neighboring property
brookside cottage looking in the
opposite direction
next one please here the photo is taken
from jetting street looking
back towards full gate the site is on
the right hand side
we have the last one please thank you
finally this phase is taken from along
jetting street looking north
the application site is cited to the
left of the photo and the trees
sighted to the right are covered by a
tpo
thank you nichola
outline permission is sought for
detached dwelling with all matters
reserved an indicative layout plan has
been included which shows one dwelling
accessed off the west side of jetting
street
with two parking spaces accessed at the
southern end of the site
the application has been accompanied by
a planning statement off-site
biodiversity enhancement survey and
reptile survey
we've had the following comments from
the consultees highways they initially
raised concerns relating to the emerging
visibility site lines for the parking
area
whilst noting the outline nature of the
application the agent provided a revised
indicative site plan to address the
visibility issues
and to demonstrate how the site can be
developed the highway authority have now
acknowledged that whilst jetting street
is not ideal
the reasons more inconvenience issues
rather than safety issues and therefore
raise
no objections environmental health
the site is adjacent to a form of quarry
use and there are elevated concentrate
concentrations of lead in soils
associated with the underlying geology
in this area there is a potential for
land contamination to be present
this would be addressed via a potential
land contamination pre-commencement
condition
derbyshire wildlife trust the details
provided within the ecological
assessment
site biodiversity plant and reptile
survey were considered to be acceptable
in securing
biodiversity enhancement on site and
raised no objections
the environment agency and lead flood
team have provided comments
as part of the site was covered by flood
zone 2 and 3. they both initially
objected on the grounds that they were
covered by this flood zone however it's
been confirmed
by both that there are mapping areas and
the flood zones are misaligned
it is also considered that given the
fact the sight light is
at a level above the river it is not
deemed to be at risk from flooding
when considering the list of building it
is not considered the proposed dwelling
would be read in context of the nearby
listed building due to the changes in
levels
and it is therefore officer opinion that
the proposed dwelling would therefore
preserve the setting of the listed
building
having taken into account all the
material considerations it is considered
that the proposed dwelling would not
accord with free strands of sustainable
development
and is therefore an unsustainable form
of development
the proposed dwelling would represent an
obtrusive encouragement into the
countryside and would have a detrimental
impact upon the character and appearance
of this special landscape area
the proposal is contrary to the aims
objectives of the development plan
as such the principle of development is
not acceptable in both local and
national planning policy terms
officers are therefore making a
recommendation of refusal
thank you chair thank you
i'll now move on to the speakers i think
we have two for this application the
first one is david thomas
yeah that's me chair thomas you have
three minutes to make your point
and you will be given a 30-second
warning before your time is up
your time starts now thank you um thank
you chad
i've twice written to the planning
department about this application
regarding what i perceived to be a
serious risk of collateral damage
to the local environment and heritage
firstly i had fears about the flooding
risk and is gratifying that the gcc
flood risk team in their report of the
14th of july
called for a flood risk assessment to be
carried out fully assessing the level of
exposure
until the arrival of this report this
kind of focus was conspicuous by its
absence
comment was also made about the
potential presence of engineering funds
in the locality
aimed at identifying whether these form
parts of the river amber defenses
and their original purpose this was my
second concern
this bond which is directly opposite the
proposed development
is in fact an embankment of the former
ashover light railway
and if heavy construction vehicles were
to be allowed through the narrow width
of jetting street along the bond
then the potential for significant
damage is easy to envisage
indeed this is understood to have been
the reason why an application in october
2003
for work near the bond was refused it
was recognized this was a very special
area
and needed to be protected a more recent
follow-up was again refused on similar
grounds
a report by the derbyshire wildlife
trust stated the area
had not been raised stated that had the
area not been raised immediately before
the planning application
as that picture showed it would have
been contributing to the overall
diversity of the local wildlife site
it would seem this is what led to the
off-site biodiversity enhancement scheme
report
whilst in principle this scheme has
attractions i have concerns about
whether it would be delivered
i say this because on a nearby site in
jetting street this applicant had stated
at both application and reserve matter
stages
that a nearby permissive footpath would
be reopened post construction
and that an adjacent heritage station
would be protected and on view
this undertaking was not honored the
footpath has been permanently closed
diverting pedestrians onto a narrow lane
while appreciation of the heritage
building is lost to the community
the purpose of highlighting these issues
is to demonstrate that the concern about
threats to the local heritage
is real hopefully the committee will
refuse this application
if it is given further consideration
then the land opposite the development
must be protected
and with strict timing deadlines
requiring the bunt
to be fully reinstated to preserve the
environment
mitigate the risk of seconds remaining
and protect the social history of the
area
there must also be a formal condition
put in place
to ensure that undertakings to create an
off-site
biodiversity enhancement scheme are
properly honored
thank you chair thank you are there any
questions
no questions chad thank you
we'll move on to the agent charlotte
stanton
hello charlotte if you've
thank you this is an outline application
for one family home it is an obvious
infill plot
with houses to each side as well as up
the hill to the rear
no objections have been raised from any
consultees including the highway
authority
environmental health environment agency
and the derbyshire wildlife trust
the starting point for considering this
application is the development plan
but as you know your settlement
development limits are out of date
and this application must be considered
with a tilted balance
in favor this means that permission
should be granted unless you have
evidence that the proposed house would
result in significant
and demonstrable harm your officers have
not provided you with evidence of
significant
harm you are advised at 7-eleven that
the economic and social benefits of
delivering one home would be limited
but this is still a small benefit and
not harm
this is not an open location and there
are no medium or long distance
landscape views of the site your offices
confirm at 7 16 that the site is well
screened from far-reaching views
this is not an isolated site you have
granted over 20 new dwellings within
walking distance
including four new dwellings in this
same row and five detached houses on the
paddock to the south
unfortunately at 3.2 your officer has
only mentioned
two of these nearby permissions we ask
you to be consistent by granting this
final
infill plot to complete the rome
it is intended that the house would have
two stories and be constructed in stone
to the same high quality as the houses
being built on the paddock
the proposed house would not be
incongruous or prominent
it would not be over development there
would be a large level
level patio level lawn or allotment area
to the south
and terraced and sloping land and
landscape rear gardens
the application includes an off-site
ecological enhancement scheme
of the type and scale you have not seen
before for a single house development
this is a significant environmental
benefit of the proposal
and i can give you more details on this
if you have any questions later
other environmental benefits include the
provision of new and
indigenous landscaping on the site as
well as making good use of this
previously overgrown scrub
area the existing trees will remain the
derbyshire wildlife trust has
confirmed that all the ecological
information is in accordance with best
practice
this is an infill development which will
provide 30 seconds remaining
on an empty site next to other dwellings
this would be in accordance with other
houses you have granted nearby
the site is not prominent and the scheme
would not harm the immunity of any
neighbours
there is no evidence that this single
infill house would result in harm
we ask you please to support this
application thank you
thank you are there any questions
questions chair thank you
thank you mrs miss stanton hey right
where are we now
if there's any comments now for the
officers
no no questions chad
are we going to put a motion forward
uh do members wish to discuss first
does anyone have any comments questions
anything castle william armitage is
indicating his wish to speak
councillor armitage i've just got a
blank screen here
uh thank you chair uh as it's been
mentioned
uh there are a number of sites along
that road
which we have allowed
and we have to be consistent
there's no significant harm and
providing that well you can't see
from anywhere uh unless you were you're
a helicopter
because uh it's surrounded by trees and
one thing in another
uh i think some of the trees that
are there already you need to put
uh some more trees around them uh
because it's to so you don't get any
uh wind damage because the way it's
being cleared the site
uh if you do that if you don't do it
you could get uh wind blow problems
uh so i've no problem with this site
no one else seems to have there's been
uh
two objections one of them was regarding
the bung
well the uh bung to stop the
river coming up uh is still in place
and it's not the subject of this planet
application
uh it's always
it's it's quite an elevated site
and i've never seen the river not even
on the road
let alone lapping up the side of this
of this house so i i have no
objection to this whatsoever
any other comments counselor mark foster
chair
councillor foster uh thank you chair
yeah
i'm inclined to go with uh officers
recommendations on this and refuse
permission
and what concerns me is all that's being
said
uh when we look at 9.1 i agree without
me reading out i
agree with all that's been said on the
recommendations
what does worry me is that uh it goes
um like it says at the end to grant
permission with the country to local
plan policies gs1 anyone in e2
um and policies ap2 ap
13 of the ashad neighborhood plan when
we're putting
uh weight on these these documents these
planning documents which
was what we're supposed to do uh we're
refusing or granting permission based on
this
and if we ignore it in this case it's
you know
it's taking the weight away for that for
away from these documents for future
uh future applications so i think we've
got to be very careful we've got enough
there
in that uh in that recommendation um
by the planning office at the end to pay
attention to so for me
um i'd like to propose that we do refuse
permission based on the officer's
recommendations so i'd like to propose
that
second nature
thank you so is that going to be carried
as a motion
the motion is chaired then to approve
officer recommendations
thank you no more comments we'll move to
the vote
um if members could clearly indicate or
against or abstain from the motion put
cancer armitage engaged
sean
abstain
casa jones or
casa liggett
for casa powell
carter reader four
that's aroused four castle rough
four and council winsley
four so chair that's 11 votes for
one against with one ab station so the
motion put
is carried thank you
thank you members just to be clear
that meant that um planning permission
has been refused
yes okay thank you
thank you members that's the final
application for this afternoon we move
on to item
five which is the the appeals lodged and
[Applause]
determined
oh dear
uh the um the sub um report is uh
in relation to the um the standard
report of uh
appeals lodged and determined it's there
for members information
um i've got nothing more to say but if
there are any questions we'll either
field them now
or get back to members another time
are there any questions
no thank you very much i've no matters
of
urgency at all
um so thank you membership
uh there is the planning enforcement
plan item
so we've got item six planning
enforcement plan
okay i'll just very quickly um if that's
okay with you
just to run through um the
headlines of um of this enforcement plan
um it sets out uh it's a public facing
uh document really to set out to members
of the public
what they can expect should they advise
the council of a suspected breach of
planning control
and the various sections related to it
one sets out the
um the national planning context in
relation to
enforcement as the
reference to the important role that
enforcement plays within the council in
terms of
supporting the role of the planetary
authority there's also in their
reference to prioritization of types of
cases
and how quickly we would look to
initiate investigations
of those depending on the um uh the
severity and the impacts of the
creatures that have been reported to us
and then there's also for the public
information
um what issues can and cannot
be investigated through planning and
fall
and we've tried to be helpful uh to be
able to
inform the public um that if it's not
planning enforcement who can investigate
their particular concern
then who else within the council might
be able to do it you know but whether
that's in relation to
um uh fly tipping or
um like posting or various other
things like that and then um there's the
the range of actions that would uh are
within the
uh armory of um planning enforcement
so those will get a um an air in in the
uh
um in the enforcement plan um it also
introduces the framework for monitoring
performance
and reporting back to the walls and
planning committee
on the workloads um uh
that's that we're having and the the
sort of cases that where
we're getting and um the
um monitoring of how
quickly we are managing to uh achieve
the standards that are being expected
from the plan
the it is the responsibility of planning
committee
uh planning enforcement is the
responsibility of planning um
committee and the uh
the recommendation is that this is
adopted as the council's enforcement
plan
and then we can um uh
if there are any um amendments to it um
then any minor amendments to it or
things that we think
actually need to be covered by it then
we can introduce that
but we're looking to have a um
a routine um amendment
um and revision process uh every four
years
so really um shortly after within the
first year of each um
uh new administration um after each
election
so so this is really introducing um
of the plan it is uh expected that each
authority has
an enforcement plan and um and this is
what we'd like to uh
um uh recommend to you as being
our sort of term engagement when it
comes to planning enforcement
thank you richard i i will add to that
that
i have actually passed on some
small recommendations for changes for
this paper which
richard has actually put forward
in a separate document so it has been
upgraded from this
at this point yes indeed
um and i could just say that um we are
working
with the cons team to um
uh turn the um
the fairly black and white
uh text that you have got on your papers
there
into something which is more um uh
easily consumed by
by the public in terms of presentation
and how the information is
delivered
thank you are there any passing comments
at this stage
or armitage wishes to speak counselor
armstage
yeah thank you chair yes uh there's
obviously
a great deal of work going into this uh
proposal
uh there's only one uh
problem with it we don't have any
enforcement officers at the moment
and can you give some indication as when
this uh
problem will be rectified
indeed um yes you're quite writing that
in as much as we've
had one um enforcement officer for about
a year who has um
uh recently left the authority um that's
the cabinet of um earlier on this month
it was agreed that we would be um going
forward
to um recruit a second enforcement
officer so we are shortly
going to go out to advert for um for
two full-time permanent enforcement
officers
that's the foster chair counselor foster
yeah thank you chair i'd like to thank
the officers for the work they've done
on this
uh and also move that we accept the
recommendations six one six two six
three without me reading them out so i'd
like to move that way follow those
recommendations
thank you second yeah
thank you any further
comments questions
any questions from members chair lovely
thank you
do people wish to vote on this at this
stage or accept it in principle
members are being asked to approve the
officer recommendations
yes chair may i suggest that a show of
hands on a vote would be appropriate
that's fine if everyone can see
although i'm just mainly a blank screen
so
my trying to get that result for you
although it's a little late now
um so um or all members of the committee
are indicating um
a vote for so i'm not seeing councillor
huckabee
are you voting for
how's the huckabee is nodding i'll ask
you two of you yes
yes thank you chair that would be
carried
thank you
urgent business thank you all for your
forbearance it's been a long day
you can all go home put your feet up
well we can you're there
good afternoon thank you see you again
soon
bye
you